nine MPs quit the Labour Party this week
and there are rumours that more could
follow including potentially some labor
Lords and councillors so how should the
party react well joining us now is the
shadow international trade secretary
Barry garden I thank you for being on
the program this morning and you listen
to the chakram you know interview laying
out his reasons for resigning from the
Labour Party how do you think labour now
needs to react to these nine and Peter
look I did listen to that interview very
carefully and I'm really confused
because chuck on the one hand says that
over the past two years things on brexit
have have changed the facts have changed
the context has changed and therefore we
need people to have a second vote on it
and yet when it comes to his own
constituency where the facts have
certainly changed she's no longer a
Labour Party Member of Parliament but an
independent he says the people in his
constituency don't have term when you
vote on it and so there's a real
inconsistency there but quite honestly
what I thought was really came across
most out of that particular interview
was that here was somebody who had no
great policy difference it was all about
personality and when it came to that bit
where you asked him about you know did
he want to become the leader of the
party it was fairly clear to me that in
effect the reason that he wanted to
leave the Labour Party was that he knew
he could never be the leader of the
Labour Party and this is about
personality let's focus in politics on
policies you know if you look at what's
happened in the last week alone and and
we see three and a half thousand jobs
going in honde under this government
because of the trade deal that they
concluded with Japan without thinking
that if Japan was able to produce cars
in Japan and import them into Europe
without tariffs then actually there may
not be a point in them having those jobs
in the UK but they could reimpose jobs
into Japan now we on the show as you
know are very very keen to talk about
policy a lot of the time last week we
did a whole report third oil industry
this week however there's more
personality
it's about personality if you will
forgive me for this one week only we are
going to focus on Westminster and you
know that we hate doing that on this
program but I've just feel that this is
the week if any week to actually know
I'll see you crazy
and let's talk about the fact that you
said earlier that your community should
face a by-election and because he would
argue that people vote for their MPs
it's something that Jeremy Corbyn
himself tweeted in 2010 in our electoral
system you've actually or MP rather than
a party leader look you do that but you
gain chucker the perfect answer to that
when you said yes well that's the
technicalities of it listen to what the
people on the streets of Stratton were
saying they were saying actually you
know they don't think that he would get
back in if he were reelected and listen
to what Heidi Allen one of the the Tory
defectors said she herself said that the
reason that they didn't want now to to
conduct by-elections was because they
would be crushed
that was her words so they know that if
they went back to the electorate the
electorate would not rien or stem but
look so the point is that they have left
the Labour Party and each one of those
Labour MPs who left the Labour Party and
actually found that at the last election
their votes went up enormous lee in
austin and indeed i was talking about
the ones who formed the independent
group and their votes went up enormous
lee and and and actually they as a
result of the manifesto that we had as a
result of the campaign that jeremy
corbyn one and the manifesto that he put
together which is a radical progressive
manifester i know you don't want to talk
about policies but it was the policies
that gave them the increase in their
votes that most of them saw so I really
don't think it's right for them simply
to say oh well that had nothing to do
with it
most MPs recognize that yes of course
we're all egotistical enough to admit do
you want to do want to say well it's all
down to me being such a wonderful person
constituents elect me but no we stand on
a manifesto we stand on policies now
what policies that Jeremy put forward
the were the ones that the people of
this country actually said yeah that
meets the me one reason that many of
EMPs gave for leaving the party was
anti-semitism and we often talk about
anti-semitism in very general terms but
I just want to focus on a little bit on
some of the things that Lee Sherman
burger has said that she his experience
cuz I think it is important to talk
about what we're talking about here now
this is a woman who lost over a hundred
members of her mother's family in the
Holocaust including someone as young as
four years old and she said that she's
been called a traitor to her country
that she's a Mossad agent she's
designers Pig her face has been imposed
on a rat or knots inspired images when
six people have been convicted of
anti-semitic hate crime and death
threats against her now it's important
to say that some of these people were
from the right yeah but some of them any
from the left as well I mean House labor
let her doubt you will have heard the
remarks that I made in Parliament on
Wednesday I very little time for the
others of that independent group but but
actually for Luciana I was deeply
saddened that she felt she had no
alternative but to leave the party
because of the racist anti-semitic abuse
that she had suffered but let's talk
about what we in the party are doing
about it and have been doing for the
past 18 months okay over that period
since the new general secretary came in
1106 complaints have been lodged 443 of
those complaints were not about members
of the labor party therefore we could
take no action about them of the
remaining 220 were found to have no
evidence backing them up okay we then
there's no phone no no no no no no there
is a problem there is a problem but I
want to quantify that problem in terms
of the complaints that have been made
you then had 146 of those which were
then taken to the first stage and they
were deemed to be people who had used a
trope without realizing that how
offensive it was and they were given a
warning
okay we then went on to people who
actually left the party if you do there
were 44 people who left the party before
their case could be heard because they
knew they were going to be expelled
we then expelled and 12 people whose
cases went to the final disciplinary
stage in the party house labor done
enough do you think look we have changed
the way in which we deal with these to
deal with them faster we weren't dealing
with them fast enough we have changed
the way we're dealing with them to make
sure that it's faster and I want to make
sure that the outcomes not just the
speed by which we process but the
outcomes are the right ones but we have
expelled now or people have gone because
they thought they were going to be
expelled 61 people from the party now
look at this one more point please
Sophia Fermi and and that is that if you
look at this as a percentage of the
labor membership we remember we have
almost 600,000 members of our party if
you look at its 0.01 percent of our
members who have been expelled and even
the totality of the complaints that we
received even those that had nothing
backing them up 0.1 percent so we're
talking about a very tiny minority in
the party that are causing huge distress
showed by the appalling way in which
their behavior sure Jeremy Corbyn had
met with Luciana Bajor more recently
than last year when this is a woman who
is receiving some absolutely vile abuse
look I don't know the details of
meetings or anything like that I've
certainly met with Luciana I've spoken
to Luciana and three to two weeks ago
just after the PLP meeting actually the
parliamentary Labour Party meeting and
but that's that's not the issue here the
issue here is are we tight is there a
problem yes there is how large is that
problem in terms of numbers it's tiny
are we dealing with it we didn't deal
with it fast enough but we now are
we're getting on top of it and that's
assurance that I really want to give
because I want everybody whether they're
from a Jewish background from any other
faith background or any ethnicity I want
them to feel at home and secure in the
labour party and so does Jeremy know I
want to just ask you about a tweet that
you put out early this week if I may we
should better show on the wall now you
this was in response to someone who
suggested you said the 7 MP equipped
labour were forced out and you said just
to be clear I did not talk about the 7
MPs I was referring to Luciana Berger I
have absolutely no time for others at
all what I don't understand is if you if
you acknowledge that Luciana bersia
if we if you understand her reasons for
leaving the party over anti-semitism why
don't you understand that some other
people in labour may feel so strongly
about it that they want to stand with
Jews lightly Shana burger this is not
just an issue for Jewish people is it no
it's not and that's why I am dedicated
in the labour party to defeating the
evil of anti-semitism that has that hold
right and but I have no time for the
others at all because actually their
reasons are varied but different many of
them personal reasons
many of them no but what I'm clear about
is that I I don't believe that that is
the sole focus of why they've left the
Labour Party right ok ok and I also want
to ask you about and something to Chrome
you know said he said this from the
interview I did with him earlier he said
I blame Jeremy Corbyn but I do blame
other people who have acted as by
standards it's disgraceful that the
Shadow Cabinet has not done more has not
been more vocal has had not threatened
to resign over what's been going on over
anti-semitism I mean are you a bystander
according to chick Ramona I think
anybody who knows what I've been doing
within the party within the Shadow
Cabinet knows I'm not a bystander ok and
now I'm keen to talk about brexit if you
want to policies and thank you very much
for talking to me about anti-semitism
and rather split now pressure is
building on the Labour Party to back a
referendum so I'm just trying to get my
head around what the latest policy
is the policy to have an election - for
a Labour government to renegotiate a
deal and then to put that deal back to
the British people is that the policy
well it certainly was our policy and
we're running out of time is the obvious
repost to that so you're right in
articulating that had had it all been
within our hands that had we been able
to program it as we wanted what we would
have done is said the deal doesn't match
up
we need the general election we would
then have a general election we would
have conducted negotiations and I think
the interesting thing is that you saw
this last week when Jeremy went to
Brussels and the way in which the
proposals that he had given - to reason
may the five proposals that we'd put in
that letter and that actually gained
real traction in Brussels and they said
look on this basis it would be possible
to have a better future political
relationships the future political
agreement that still needs to be
negotiated not the withdrawal agreement
but the future political agreement and
could be changed on the basis of that
offer now that's why we made it because
we believe that it's not right to offer
the the people of this country have
false perspectives between No Deal and
her deal remembering that her deal lost
by the largest margin any government has
ever lost a debate in a thousand years
of Parliament's history so you know
given that that's where we are with this
and it's ridiculous that we're going on
and she is trying to wind down the clock
so that she can still say well you've
now got to vote for the deal that even
most of my own party didn't want because
the alternative is no deal do you isn't
arresting what you're saying at the
beginning that the clocks running down
it certainly is realistically do you
think a second referendum was going to
happen
I think it's look we've always said
since the composite motion at Party
conference that we would not exclude a
second referendum precisely because we
cannot risk no deal the closer we get to
no deal the more important that safety
net of a
referendum comes and and what I think
we're seeing in this coming week is is
the movement towards that as as that
safety net against no deal but what we
want to do in the party is not have that
to be a false position which is it's
instead of it being her Deal or No Deal
it's her deal or a second referendum or
her deal in a second reference remain if
we're going to the people it has to be
on a real choice of something that is
credible her deal is not credible and
that's why we put forward our proposals
that's why given how they've been
received in Europe we believe there is
the possibility of a consensus in
Parliament around that which then yes
could be put to the the people in a
public vote and I think actually if you
remember back to a couple of times ago
when I was on your program I think I
said something quite similar there did
view at that stage right I don't know
whether we'll get there we've still got
to decide the amendments that are going
to be put down and of course there's
been a helpful amendment and from Phil
Wilson and and Peter Kyle but actually
unfortunately that would mean focusing
on support for the prime ministers deal
so there's talks going on with them I
hope we'll find a way through a Barry
garner we're out of time thank you very
much now in the last few moments the
Labour Party press office has been in
touch responding to an allegation made
by chakram you know in my interview with
him earlier in the show he said that
Jeremy Corbyn said Jewish people have no
sense of irony and the Labour Party wish
to make it clear they dispute this
allegation and they say that Jeremy
Corbyn was referring to two specific
individuals not Jewish people as